difficile de prendre la parole après de
très belles choses et j'espère que je
vais pas vous
je m'appelle bois car ça y est je me
défile et souvent comment sahélien ma
mère et malienne mon père est sénégalais
et chênée en mauritanie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien
commençons par la pomme de newton j'ai
pas ce que vous la voyez parce que sinon
on avait faim il aurait croqué la pomme
et c'est pas le dire mais pourquoi elles
manquent pas quand on a faim on ne
réfléchit pas on mange
[Applaudissements]
après tout ce qui a été dit aujourd'hui
surtout sur l'eau l'humain la
technologie la connaissance le soir la
volonté de puissance
il estime de soi c'est ce qui a été dit
aujourd'hui
l'être humain est capable de faire de
belles choses
le faire des choses extraordinaires
archimède car je me disais de l'émoi en
point d'appui et olivier et je vous lève
le monde tous les mois un point d'appui
et olivier et je vous lève le monde
souvent sans doute vous voyez des
groupes en train de tirer
vous allez au port autonome de dakar
vous voyez des groupes afin de prendre
des conteneurs de 40 pieds
l'être humain nous on est capable de
faire des choses extraordinaires quand
on sait dans la main entre nos tout à
l'heure mais dit bamba vraiment tous ont
parlé de ce qu'on pouvait faire pour
l'afrique tous ont dit mais comment se
fait-il que ce continent si riche
ces faits tels que ceux contenant six
peuples et si bout sur le plus pauvre au
monde
il faut changer quelque chose dans notre
état d'esprit et ma le disais ma
spéciaux se lève ce ms pts elf voix
maple slavery et n'est pas du physique
et mentale l'échelle ça dans la tête
marche pas dave suis pas ingénieur j'ai
fait des études un plan sciences
politiques un point en philosophie en
histoire question de bourlinguer un peu
mais c'est que
j'ai découvert de très intéressant
c'était la philosophie du plongeur un
jour j'étais en france et je nettoyais
des assiettes pour payer mes étés tout
j'avais une pile d'assiettes salle alec
j'ai commencé à déployer 2 3 4 5 6 si je
marque mais c'est la dernière assiette
de la peel sale qui la première de la
pile propres il a fait beaucoup de
plongeurs ici vous avez une pile
d'assiettes ça vous fait l'essai de
déployer
c'est la dernière de la peel sale qui
devient la première dame a pill propres
je me suis dit mais man fait quelque
chose si tu fais quelque chose je me
trouverai un brin le premier temps
génération fait quelque chose c'est que
c'est assez délaissé attendant une
semaine que je ne fais rien mais rien ne
se passera pas ce que c'est des
assiettes
nous sommes de l'eau sont des êtres
humains capables de faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire nous sommes des génies
souvent j'aime bien dire à main en lui
disant l'afrique n'a pas besoin des
dictateurs l'afrique a besoin de coach
en développement personnel
les quelques audaces ses enfants
d'afrique et qui leur disent vous êtes
les meilleurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on dit
africains ont dit combien elle joue bien
au foot quand tu parles de finance de
comptabilité on dit je préférerais ce
qui est ce qu'ils se le faire cette
présentation des compétences aujourd'hui
faut vous battre et pour créer quelque
chose de grand il faut nous battre pour
exister parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
vivent mais il n'existe pas il ya des
différences entre vivre et exister quand
on existe le propose à nous quand on vit
personne ne pense à nos forcément c'est
comme si on sortait des si et quand on
se rappelle pas à quoi ressemble son
voisin de droite ou de gauche
et quand on existe on dire à mes gars de
gang et tu l'as vu avec sa tête un peu
farfelu ses chaussures c'est à dire vous
avez fait attention à nous et
aujourd'hui il faut que l'afrique
attention à ses enfants il faut que
l'afrique se disent qu'il n'est pas
condamné à l'échec
il ya quelques années un homme thucydide
tous ces décès le père de l'histoire de
la vraie parce que souvent on dit que c
est remettre le père de l'histoire m'est
aussi dit était celui qui disait la
vérité et rien que la vérité
il disait il y avait une piste à athènes
et le dit j'écris pour que la génération
qui viendra après nous sache comment
s'est débrouillé avec la peste
comment ou l'invaincu pour qu'elle
puisse tirer des leçons de nos erreurs
et on dit souvent un peuple qui ne sait
pas tirer des leçons du passé et
condamné à les reproduire nous faut
tirer des leçons de nos échecs
c'est ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire en même temps où
votre parcours votre chemin
en france cet homme-là qui était en
train de scier le shell je fais
quelle est la morale de l'histoire c'est
peut-être dû prendre l'échelle l ai fait
d'autres choses mais il était là pour un
confort immédiat
combien d'africains pour en confort
immédiat ou détourné de l'argent qui
n'étaient pas les leurs ont volé quelque
chose qui ne leur appartenait pas et est
pressé de peur d'être de faire le kéké
pourra le prendre d'épinés l'argent
d'une banque qui n'était pas le leur le
paraître ne paraître c'est tout à
l'heure c'était des mêmes lots qu'ils
aient besoin de savoir qui on est le
stim de soi la conscience de soi la
volonté de puissance la volonté de
s'extirper d'une situation dans laquelle
au nez et qui ne plaît pas l'homme est
un génie
l'homme est capable de changer sa vie
quand on est unis quand on est solidaire
on est capable de faire des choses
extraordinaires
parler d'agilité de l'eau souvent on dit
il faut s'adapter comme hulu l'être
humain est un génie si le seul capable
d'observer la nature et nouvel appareil
volant et mettant la zone naturelle
avion c'est la nuit j'ai créé une start
up parce que à un moment donné j'étais
en france j'avais ton confort carte
vitale salaire tout confort et je
pouvais me soigner quand je voulais être
que je veux mes frères j'ai parfois été
obligé de maps et en france pour que je
leur envoie de l'argent on s'est dit on
va créer une entreprise mais je ne
savais même pas si de quoi en france
d'autant que j'allais demander à
quelqu'un qui savait en fait pour savoir
où on connaît quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un
aujourd'hui le monde
il est ouvert le message que je veux
transmettre c'est quand on écoute urbain
d'ailleurs je te fais une clin d'oeil
tout le monde passe à ces touffes de
cheveux à ce qu'il a dit sur la
confiance sur la sagesse sur la femme
mais à ceux qui me plaisent toujours ce
qu'il a dit
quand obama a dit le travail libère
l'homme ce n'est que par le travail
ce n'est pas par leur respect c'est
l'été par l'amour du prochain qu'on est
capable de faire quelque chose de grand
c'est quand on subit soi même que l'on
est capable de faire des jeux dont le
monde souvient
quand on est là et que vous on a envie
de conduire une grosse voiture pour que
ceux qui n'ont pas de voiture et se
disent ouais il a réussi non ce n'est
pas vraiment de sens si les routes
étaient très bien fait on aurait pu
prendre un vélo et aller au boulot parce
que moi je connais des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'argent et qui ont voulu un
vélo pour aller au bureau ce que les
gens pensent de vous le plus important
c'est que vous vous même vos pensées de
vous un moment donné je me suis dit
l'afrique pourquoi j'ai accepté de venir
parce que j'ai quelque chose à vous
transmettre vous vous pouvez être ce que
vous voulez être vous pouvez transformer
votre vie mettant police est pas facile
c'est des sacrifices c'est des
sacrifices et l'homme n'est pas un ange
on était des êtres humains moi j pal ce
genre qui va vous dire ouais je cost ou
non quand j'ai trait sur leur même quand
je regarde un bon film je pleure car ma
famille à ma femme me dit avec notre
boulot je lis mon amour j'arrive je
laime en fait je suis sans n'être images
en imprimant je ne suis pas parfait il
faut que les gens arrêtent de vouloir
passer pour des anges
on est des êtres humains mais c'est en
connaissant mon limites qu'on est
capable de faire des grandes choses
c'est un s'associant associant on veut
bédié m'a appris quelque chose
si vous avez une part d intelligence
économique et que vous êtes capable
d'analyser ce qu'il a dit c'était demain
l'afrique sera connecté c'était demain
vous serez malade parce vous voulez
bravo médicaments à la maison c'est ça
demain demain sera beaucoup plus beau on
sera beaucoup plus riches et à dakar le
rein de fleurs et des arbres devant la
gare sera très boueux sera écologique où
elle ne sera pas demain je donnerais un
tesla model s voiture électrique est
long et sens demain demain et se
concentreront aujourd'hui notre demande
est revenu deux fois aujourd'hui des
digues et moi on ne savait pas nelson
mandela est revenu vous savez pourquoi
il est revenu c'est un homme qui assume
et la violence il a subi l'injustice
mais quand il est sorti de la prison et
l'a pardonné le malheur des peuples
dominés c'est qu'une fois libérés ils
veulent ressembler aux dominants au lieu
de se réinventer
quelqu'un qui a subi le racisme
doit être raciste à son pour quelqu'un
qui a subi l'injustice voudrait être à
son tour
quelqu'un qui a su mêler posions voudra
se poser à son tour n'ont pas aimé être
humble simple il nous faut donner de
l'amour parce que comme des condéens des
sages le temps en temps il faut montrer
tda pour mme après que tu sais mordre
mais ne marque pas je suis monté dans
nelson mandela est cet homme là qui m'a
donné l'esprit du pardon je vous disais
tout à l'heure je n'ai amourette année
j'ai grandi au sénégal
j'ai vécu une partie une bonne partie de
ma vie en france à toulouse
j'ai subi le racisme en mauritanie parce
que je te le seul voire de mon école je
suivais le racisme au sénégal parce que
je parlais pas au lof
j'ai subi le racisme en france parce que
voilà je pars tu n'es pas au phénotype
de milan alors le racisme et humains
contre plusieurs cibles que j'aie vu
dans le monde
je veux donner la tolérance et la
solidarité nous autorise non merci